[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم قالت مصادر خاصه
للجزيره ان المعارضه السوريه المجتمعه في
الرياض اتفقت على عده نقاط اهمها تاكيد
وحده اراضي سوريا وان حل الازمه هو حل
سياسي يعتمد على بيان جناف واحد كاطار
وحيد لحل يؤدي لتاسيس نظام جديد بدون بشار
الاسد نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما هي ابعاد ومدى وحجم الاتفاق بين
اطراف المعارضه السوريه المجتمعين في
الرياض ما هي دلالات التوافق بين اطراف
المعارضه السوريه وتاثير ذلك على مسار
الثوره ومسارات التفاوض
[موسيقى]
الاخرى كان مجرد اجتماع اطراف المعارضه
السوريه في الرياض خطوه مهمه بحد ذاتها
ولكن ورود انباء عن توصل هذه الاطراف
لاتفاقات وتوافقات فيما بينها من اول يوم
للاجتماعات التي تستمر ليومين اخرين يحمل
او يجعل بدوره اهميه اكبر بكثير اهميه
تثير الكثير من التفاؤل ولكنها تثير ما هو
اكثر من التساؤلات بشان الاتفاق النهائي
الذي ستسفر عنه اجتماعات الرياض وما ستثير
من ردود فعل وما سيلي ذلك من خطوات
التقرير لزياد
بركات الاجتماع في الرياض اما الحسم فهناك
على الارض هنا حمص وقد كانت شوكه في حلق
النظام من تسميهم روسيا والاسد ارهابيين
يخرجون من حي الوعر الذي كان له من اسمه
نصيب لقد صمدوا وحاربوا في مدينه احتضنت
ثوره شعبهم على ما يقولون انه طاغيه الشام
وهاهم وقد تغيرت المعادلات ميدانيا يضطرون
الى ما يكرهون تسويه صغيره يعرفون قبل
غيرهم انها لن توصلهم الى الحل الكبير
الذي يسعون اليه فثم ما تغير وهو كثير منه
انهم وامثالهم اصبحوا في صراع مع موسكو
ايضا التي تستعرض اسلحتها في البر والجو
والبحر فتطلق صواريخ كروز من غواصه
للترهيب وبعث الرسائل الى الكثيرين في
المنطقه والاقليم لقد اسقط لهم الاتراك
طائره فاحدث جرحا غائرا في سيكولوجيا
رئيسهم بوتين الذي يتحين الفرصه للرد
بينما تواصل طائراته وهي كثيره قصف مواقع
في الداخل السوري واغلبها مدني او خاضع
لقوات
المعارضه
في مثل هذه الظروف تدعو الرياض معارضي
الاسد على مختلف الوانهم السياسيه فيجون
يعقدون مؤتمرهم ويتفقون على ما كان
تاريخيا محل اجماع لدى الشعب السوري اي
على وحده اراضيهم وعلى ان الحل سياسي
ومرجعيته بيان جنيف واحد وعليه يرفضون
وجود المقاتلين الاجانب وفي تعريفهم
لهؤلاء فانهم مسلحون تابعون لحزب الله
اللبناني ومستشارون جنرالات ايرانيون
اضافه الى الوافد الجديد على الارض
السوريه وهو الوجود الروسي الاخذ في
التوسع ثمه ما يضاف لدى المجتمعين في
الرياض وهو ضروره الالتزام بالديمقراطيه
في سوريا الغد والمسائله والمحاسبه الله
اكبر يعرف هؤلاء كما المجتمعون في الرياض
ان الرد على القصف الروسي وما تفعله قوات
رئيسهم لا يكون فحسب باصدار بيان وان
القتلى هنا كما اخلاء كثير من مناطق
البلاد من المقاتلين والمساعي المحمومه
لخلق مناطق صافيه طائفيه هي امور تغير من
طبيعه البلاد كما يعرف الروس وقد اصبحت
علاقاتهم اوثق بال الايرانيين بعد ان
توحدوا في وجه عدو جديد ان الصراع تجاوز
حدوده القديمه لم يعد في سوريا او عليها
بل على الاقليم لذلك ستلتقي وفود منهم مع
وفد يمثل الاسد اما الهدف فهو التاثير
مسبقا على فينا المقبل والتحكم في اجندته
فما يعنيهم في نهايه المطاف هو بقاء هذا
الرجل ومصالحهم فالاجتماع وسواها تعني
غيرهم انضم الينا من واشنطن دوجلاس اوليف
كبير الباحثين في قضايا الامن القومي
بمؤسسه امريكا الجديده والمستشار السابق
لشؤون الامن القومي للرئيس بارك اوباما
سيد اوليفانت بايه عين ترقب واشنطن
اجتماعات المعارضه السوريه في
الرياض
اعتقد ان واشنطن تشعر بتشجيع من ما سمعت
من بيانات وتصريحات من الرياض وان كان ذلك
بعيدا عن الحوار الكبير الموجود القول بان
نريد كل مقاتلين الجانب ان يغادر البلاد
امر غير مقبول الان فالروس هناك في سوريا
ومن الواضح انهم لن يغادروا قريبا وهذا
واقع لابد من مواجهته وبالتالي القول لا
يبقى اي جانب في البلاد قبل سته اشهر كان
يمكن ان يكون مقبولا اما اليوم فهو ليس
يمكن يكون معترفا بالواقع الموجود على
الارض ولا كذلك يتعامل مع كثير من القضايا
التي تثير قلق القوى الخارجيه وهي
اساسا انبعاث داعش او تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه وتدفق اللاجئين خارج البلاد
وبالتالي ف اولويه للغرب وهذا امر يهم وضا
الروس هوهان الشيئان التخلص من تنظيم
الدوله وايقاف تدفق اللاجئين الى خارج
البلاد او الدول المجاوره وغيرها سالتك
سيد اوليفنت عن رؤيه واشنطن للمجتمعين
خاصه وان هناك اطياف من المعارضه
العسكريه المسلحه التي تنشط في الداخل
السوري ونحن جميعا نعرف بان واشنطن كانت
قد وضعت شروطا لهذه المعارضه حتى تنضوي في
ايه مفاوضات هل لدى واشنطن علم بالمجتمع
هناك وكيف ترى هذه الاجتماعات من وجهه
نظرها اعتقد وبشكل عام واشنطن سعيده بحصول
هذا الاجتماع ولكنها تفهم حدود امكانيات
نتائج هذا الاجتماع فهذه مجموعه صغيره
النسبيه من دول لل المعارضه من متبين
اسلاميين مثل داعش والنصره غير موجودين
ولا غالبيه الاكراد ووحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه ولكن قد تنتج اشياء جيده عن هذا
الاجتماع ولكن ذلك كل لان لكن هؤلاء هم
مجرد جزء من المعارضه وان كانت يضم بعض
الفصائل الذين تفضلهم واشنطن وبالتالي فان
واشنطن توافق بشكل عام على هذا الاجتماع
ولكنها لا ترى ان هذا هو الحل الشامل
المرجو للازمه السوريه اذا واشنطن يعني
راضيه عن هذه الاجتماعات والمجتمعين فيها
وتنتظر نتائج ايجابيه وجيده باعتقادك يعني
نود ان نستفسر قليلا عن المامول من وجهه
النظر الامريكيه تحدث عن نقطتين اثنتين لا
ثالثه لهما وقف تدفق اللاجئين ومحاربه
تنظيم الدوله ماذا عن مطالبات المعارضه
السوريه التي خرجت في ثوره
سلميه
ان واشنطن وبشكل عام تتعاطف مع مطالب
الشعب السوري ولكن نوع الحكومه التي
موجوده في سوريا ليست من المصلحه الوطنيه
الاساسيه بالنسبه لواشنطن يجب ان يفهم ذلك
هناك ناس يعانون في العالم كله تحت حكومات
مستبده ولا تستطيع واشنطن مساعدتهم جميعا
هذه حقيقه مؤلمه ولكن نحن لدينا مصلحه
وطنيه واضحه وهي هذ النقطتين اللي ذكرتهما
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وتدفق اللاجئين
اما كيفكون حكومه في سوريا عندما بشرط
توقف الحراب لكي يمكن التفرغ
لقتال تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه عده
اللاجئين اما بقيه ذلك فليس بالمهم
بالنسبه لواشنطن دعنا نوسع النقاش قليلا
وقد انضم الينا الان من الكويت السيد عبد
الله
الشايجي وهو استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الكويت نرحب به السيد عبد الله
الشايجي من خلال ما اعلن من توافقات تم
توصل صل اليها الى حد الان في هذا اليوم
الاول من اجتماعات الرياض كيف بدات
لك يعني خطوه متاخره ولكن في الاتجاه
الصحيح هذه المبادره السعوديه تشكر عليه
السعوديه وفي اشاده بها من قبل القاده
الخليجيين استمعنا الى كلمات القاده و
هناك ترحيب بهذه بهذا مؤتمر الفصائل
السوريه المعارضه المشكله كانت دائما ان
يعني في تراجع او عدم وجود عربي فا في رفع
اليد الامريكي يعني واضح جدا ان امريكا
بدات تهتم بشكل اكبر بعد ان تدخلت روسيا
وبعد ان اصبحت داعش خطر عالمي يضرب في
اوروبا ويضرب في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتدفع الى مواجهه بين الاسلام
وبين الغرب وبعد ان اصبحت مساله اللاجئين
يعني نقطه سوداء في جبين الغرب الذي دائما
يتكلم عن التسامح واستقبال المهاجرين
واللاجئين اصبح الان يصد ابوابه ويحمل
يعني تركيا اكثر مما تحتمل لهذا السبب
هناك اهتمام اكبر الان امريكا لم تكن
سوريا من ضمن الاولويات الاستراتيجيه لها
لان يعني الوضع في سوريا بسبب العدم يعني
دور وجود دور امريكي وغربي فاعل منذ
البدايه للتاثير على مجريات ما يجري داخل
سوريا ترك المجال للنظام في سوريا وحلفائه
بان يفعلوا ما يريدون وذلك لحمايه ستاتس
الامر الواقع وعدم تهديد امن اسرائيل
للخطر عندما نزع السلاح الكيماوي من الاسد
اصبح الان مطلوب ان يبقى هذا النظام لاطول
مده ممكنه لان البديل نجح يعني النظام
وحلفائه بان يجعلوا مفاضله بين النظام
القائم بلا انياب وبلا مخالب وبين الفوضى
وعدم الاستقرار الذي واجهته داعش والفصائل
السوريه الاخرى
المتناحرين بعضهم بعضا ولهذا السبب مؤتمر
الرياض جدا مهم لوضع بعض النقاط على
الحروف لض ولوضع اليه واضحه ولتشكيل جبهه
موحده للتعامل مع النظام وضع نقاط على
الحروف وتشكيل جبهه ايهما يسبق الاخر
تشكيل هذه الجبهه التي في نهايه الامر
اقصى ما يؤمل منها هو وفد مفاوض لايه
مؤتمرات او نقاشات او
لقاءات قد تحدث مستقبلا ام فعليا تشكيل
ارضيه مشتركه وتوافق و توحد الرؤيه
والتنسيق بين اطياف المعارضه
المختلفه يعني راينا الانتصارات الكبيره
حققها جيش الفتح في الجبهه الشماليه عندما
توحدت الفصائل السوريه وتوحد الموقف
الخليجي يعني ايضا الموقف الخليجي لعب دور
مهم خاصه السعوديه وقطر وكذلك تركيا عندما
لعبوا دور مهم في دعم هذه الفصائل التي
حققت انتصارات وراينا صواريخ التاو كيف
اعاقت التقدم السوري وكذلك افش شلت الخطه
الروسيه بان يكون هناك قصف جوي تمهيدا
وحرب بريه تشن لاضعاف وضرب المعارضه
السوريه المسلحه فشلت خططهم الان ال يعني
هناك مشكله كبيره امنيه روسيا صل شهرين
ونصف لم تحقق اي انتصار سوى قتل الابرياء
وان تعيث فسادا في سوريا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقصف الان منذ منذ سنه وشهرين
دون ان تحقق نتائج دخلت الان فرنسا دخلت
بريطانيا بعد حادثه باريس ولكن المطلوب
كما ذكرت جبهه موحده ما قدمته يعني في
تناقض انا في اعتقادي لما تتكلم عن حل
سياسي الكل يتكلم عن حل سياسي عندما تتكلم
عن دوله مدنيه كيف كيف نصل الى هذه
المعادله دوله مدنيه في سوريا عندنا فصائل
اسلاميه يمكن لا تتفق مع وجود دوله
اسلاميه دوله مدنيه فهه الشيطان في
التفاصيل ولكن
الم التفا دكتور شيجي سنفصل في هذه
التفاصيل لكن اسمح لي الان ان نقرب الصوره
اكثر فاكثر الى داخل هذه الاجتماعات التي
تحدث في الرياض وانضم الينا الان من
الرياض السيد سالم المسلط المتحدث باسم
الائتلاف الوطني السوري نود ان نعرف سيد
سالم وانت في قلب هذه الاجتماعات ما حجم
التوافق الحقيقي الموجود بين مختلف هذه
الاطراف من المعارضه السوريه المجتمعه في
الرياض مساء الخير سيدت الكريمه اي مساء
الخير بضيوفك الكرام والساده المشاهدين
حقيقه اي اليوم
كان يوم طويل لكنه يوم مفيد جدا اولا
اهميه هذا المؤتمر انه يعقد في الرياض
الرياض يعني حريصه هي كانت بجانب دائما
الشعب السوري ضد هذا النظام ضد هذا
الاستبداد وحريصه ان
ينجح اللقاء يعني كانت نقاط جدا مهمه
ولاحظنا هناك اطراف متعدده من المعارضه
هناك الائتلاف الوطني السوري هناك ال هيئه
تنسيق و حتى هناك يعني لاول مره قاده من
القيادات العسكريه في الداخل الفاعله في
الداخل كان هناك توافق كامل على عده نقاط
يعني اجتزناها اليوم لم يكن اي خلاف ربما
ملاحظه هنا او هناك لكن نحن نحرص وجئنا
الى الرياض لننجح نحن كسوريين وايضا لننجح
يعني جهود المملكه يعني هذا حرص من الجميع
كانت الامور كان جو المؤتمر ايجابي بشكل
كبير نامل يعني سيكون اكمال المؤتمر يوم
غد بمناقشه سيد سالم اذا اجواء ايجابيه
ونيه حقيقيه للتوصل الى شيء لكن عناوين
عريضه عندما يجري مثل ما كان يقول الدكتور
عبد الله الشايجي عندما يجي الحديث عن
وحده الاراضي السوريه حل سياسي يرتكز
ومرجعيته جناف واحد ضروره الالتزام
بالديمقراطيه في سوريا الغد ورفض الارهاب
بما فيه ارهاب الدوله تبقى عناوين عريضه
ماذا عن عن التفاصيل كيف يمكن ان تشكل
حقيقه ارضيه صلبه لحل حقيقي يمكن ان يعتد
به اي يعني جرى مناقشه كل التفاصيل داخل
هذا المؤتمر انما ربما خرج الاعلام بعض
العناوين كما تفضلتي
اي ليس من خلاف هناك بين
ال الاطراف المعارضه لا يمكن لي ان افصل
حتى يخرج البيان يعني يمكن ان يعني تطرق
لبعض الامور لكن التفصيل يعني متروك لصدور
البياني وما غد بمشيئه الله لكن يعني امور
كثيره تم مناقشتها يعني كان تجاوب ايجابي
ايضا من القيادات العسكريه الفاعله في
الداخل يعني همنا جميعا ان تنتهي هذه
المعاناه تفضل ضيفك الاخ العزيز الدكتور
عبد الله الشاجي وقال عن يعني عن روسيا
وايران والنظام وغير يعني حقيقه سوريا
الان هي تخضع لاحتلال احتلال ايراني
واحتلال روسي يعني غارات جويه قصفت كل شيء
في سوريا باستثناء داعش التي جاءت بحجه
محاربه الارهاب محاربه الارهاب ليست بهذا
الشكل اعود الى موضوع المؤتمر لا اريد ان
اخرج بعيدا عن ذلك لكن هو يعني هدف للجميع
ان نخرج متفقين ونامل يعني غدا ان تجري
الامور كما جرت بسلاسه هذا اليوم امور
كثيره مهمه جدا
ستتضح نقاطها وتفاصيلها بشكل كامل يوم غد
بمشيئه الله طبعا نرجو ان تبقى معنا وكذا
ضيفين
الكريمين ننتقل الان مشاهدينا الكرام الى
فاصل قصير سنواصل بعده النقاش حول موضوع
حلقتنا هذه ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام من جديد
ونرحب مره اخرى بضيوفنا الكرام اتحول الى
واشنطن مره اخرى والسيد اوليفنت هناك سمعت
ما جرى من نقاش بيننا وبين ضيوفنا الان هل
تتوقع ان يقبل المجتمع الغربي والولايات
المتحده بما يمكن ان تتوصل اليه مختلف
الاطراف المجتمعه في
الرياض ان الحلفاء الاخرين الغربين
سيقبلون ذلك اذا ما كانت التوافق مع
المصالح الوطنيه للمجتمع المدني العفوا
المجتمع الدولي وكما قلت عده مرات ان
مصالح الغرب هي التوصل وقف اطلاق النار
لايقاف القتال في سوريا لكي يمكن اعاده
اللاجئين او على الاقل ايقاف تدفق
اللاجئين
وبالتالي بحيث تنصب كل الجهود على محاربه
والحاق الهزيمه بتنظيم
الدوله ايضا النصره اذا امكن واذا ما هذا
البيان سيكون دعما لهذا هذين الهدفين اي
لجعل الفصائل التركيه
والسعوديه تسير في نفس اتجاه ورغبات القوى
الخارجيه فان تلك النتائج ستقبل اعتقد ان
نحن الان في مرحله نجد ان القوى الخارجيه
لديها راي ولا تقوله وتقرر فيما يحصل في
سوريا سواء كانت روسيا وفرنسا والولايات
المتحده والسعوديه وبالتالي ن هنا في موقع
ان القوى الخارجيه لابد ايضا ان توافق على
ما يحصل واعتقد هذا امر مؤسف بالنسبه
للناس على الارض ولكن هذا هو التقييم
الصحيح او الدقيق للوضع الذي نحن فيه
حاليا في هذا الوقت من النزاع مره اخرى
سيد عبد الله الشايجي سمعت ما ذكره ضيفان
من واشنطن ومن الرياض هذا التوافق الذي
تحدث عنه تحديدا ضيفنا من الرياض بين
مختلف الاطراف باعتقادك الى اين يمكن ان
يدفع باي اتجاه يمكن ان يدفع مسا
الثوره السوريه ومجمل الازمه السوريه بما
يتوافق ويتواجه الغربيه كما سمعناها على
لسان السيد اوليفانت
طبعا يعني مهم جدا تشكيل جبهه موحده هذا
مهم جدا القاده في اليوم في الكلمات
الافتتاحيه في القمه ال6 في الرياض يعني
توجهوا بمل المعارضه السوريه بان توحد
صفوفها وتتكاتف من اجل ان تشكل جبهه موحده
وهذا هو المطلوب الان ص قد تكون هي
المشكله ما هو يعني جنيف واحد هو المرجعيه
هل تتفق مع ذلك القوى الاخرى المناو يعني
هناك الان اجتماع ايضا يعقد في طهران يضم
روسيا ونظام ممثلين النظام السوري وكذلك
ايران يعني تحالف الثنائي الروسي الايراني
لديه وجهه نظر حول مستقبل الاسد ماه بين
موقع الاسد وجنيف واحد حتى الامريكان هلهم
متمسكين بجنيف واحد ام فينا اثنين يعني
هناك في التباس واضح هناك يمكن الامريكان
يريدون من المعارضه وهذا الخطا الفادح
الذي احذر المعارضه منه ان تتحول الى
صحوات تقاتل عرضا النظام او داعش من اجل
ان يكون هناك قدره على ان يكون في تغيير
داخل التركيبه او الوضع العسكري الميداني
لا يمكن ان نستجلب النظام او تجربه العراق
الفاشله سواء بالصح وت التي تم التخلي
عنها بعدما هزمت القاعده في غرب العراق
وعدم ادماجها في الجيش العراقي او بالنظام
الطائفي المحاصصه لمستقبل سوريا ان يكون
الرئيس من هذه الطائفه ورئيس الوزراء من
هذه الطائفه وتوزع الكيكه السوريه حسب
الطوائف والاعراق هناك خطر فعلي اذا لم
يكن هناك رؤيه واضحه رفض لمصطلح لان
الامريكان مشكلتهم لا يحققون انتصار اذا
ما كان في حليف استراتيجي قوي على الارض
يمكنه ان يحقق انتصارات ضد الاولويه
الامريكيه ليست اسقاط النظام ترى خلينا
نكون واضحين ولا الغربيه ولا الروسيه ولا
الايرانيه اولويه هي محاربه داعش ولا
يمكنك ان تحارب داعش ويبقى النظام السوري
كلاهما يعني يشكلان تكامل بين بعضهما
البعض ووجهان لعمله واحده اذا ما في
اقتناع عند الاطراف المعنيه القوى الفاعله
خاصه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بان
هزيمه النظام تضعف داعش فنحن سنبقى نراوح
مكاننا و عندنا معارضه سوريه موحده ولكن
على الارض سيبقى الوضع للاسف ينزف كما هو
لفتره لان الطبخه لا تزال غير جاهزه
بالنسبه للاطراف المعنيه سواء كانوا في
الغرب او كانت روسيا وحليفتها ايران اها
اذا عن هذه الطبخه سنتحول مره اخرى للرياض
والسيد سالم في حدود المسموح لك بالتصريح
به يعني الى اي مدى هذه المظله الجامعه
لمختلف اطياف المعارضه التي تسعون
لتشكيلها بالفعل قادره على انضاج هذه
الطبخه التي تلقى القبول داخليا من مختلف
الاطياف سياسيه وعسكريه وتلقى القبول
خارجيا ايضا مع مختلف الشروط التي يضعها
الغرب ل هذا الاجتماع وما يمكن ان يترتب
عنه وكذا التفاوض ايضا
لاحقا
اي الحقيقه يعني الموجودين في الرياض في
هذا
المؤتمر
يمثلون الداخل السوري السوري باكمله لذلك
هناك يعني
تفاهمات على يعني امور كثيره
لكن الوضع لم يعد يعني نظال الشعب السوري
ضد نظام فقط هناك كما اسلفت هناك دول تحتل
سوريا مثل روسيا وايران وهناك
مليشيات لا يمكن للسوريين يعني وحدهم
ان يعني ينهوا هذه الحاله ان لم يكن هناك
دعم دولي بهذا الاتجاه حقيقه يعني نستند
لدول
هي حليفه بطبيعه الحال للشعب السوري دول
مجلس التعاون
تركيا المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه ايضا
يعني نعول على هذه الدول نعول على دعمها
وهناك ايضا اصدقاء للشعب السوري نتمنى ان
يقفوا وقفه حقيقيه مع الشعب السوري
كما ذكر الدكتور عبد الله بالنسبه لموضوع
الارهاب يعني
السوريين لا يتحولون الى صحوات يعني
تعريفنا للارهاب يختلف ربما عن تعريف
البعض الارهاب في سوريا ليس فقط داعش داعش
هو طرف يعني طرف ارهابي يجب محاربته لكن
لا نحارب هذا دون محاربه الاخر الطرف
الارهابي الحقيقي هو النظام وميليشيات جاء
بها من جاء
بداعش النظام هو الذي الذي جاء بداعش هو
الذي زج
يعني بكل قوى الارهاب استورد كل قوى
الارهاب الى الى سوريا ليظهر صوره صورته
امام العالم انه المحارب الوحيد للارهاب
الجيش الحر حارب حارب داعش منذ نشاتها في
البدايه حتى ان يتحدث في عجال لو تكرمت في
عجله لو تكرمت الان هذه الاجتماعات ما
المامول منها توحيد صفوف المعارضه مظله
موحده لكل هؤ لا لكن باي غرض توحدت وتوحدت
المواقف ماذا بعد الخطوه التاليه
نعم همنا الاكبر ان تنتهي معاناه الشعب
السوري هذا يعني بالدرجه الاولى قبل كل
شيء ا يعني هناك لقاء في نيويورك اعتقد 18
الشهر الحالي هناك مقترح ان تبدا
المفاوضات في بدايه في شهر كانون الثاني
يناير بدايه العام الجديد لكن اي يعني
نامل ان نخرج
بنتائج هي ليست بعيده عن ثوابت هذه الثوره
يعني الثوره قامت على يعني لاهداف محدده
نامل تحقيقها لكن بنفس الوقت لن نحمل
السلم بالعرض ويعني ونتحدث هكذا لكن نامل
بالنهايه ان ننهي معاناه الشعب يعني الشعب
السوري حقيقه بهه المحنه اشكرك جزيل الشكر
سيد سالم المسلط المتحدث باسم الائتلاف
الوطني السوري معارض كنت معنا من الرياض
كما نشكر جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من الكويت عبد
الله الشايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الكويت ومن واشنطن دوجلاس اوليفنت
كبير الباحثين في قضايا الامن القومي
والمستشار السابق لشؤون الامن القومي
للرئيس باراك اوباما ذا مشاهدينا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر
جديد السلام
عليكم
ا